the doctor was like she's gonna outlive
you all
right Keith Richards
this show is brought to you by meandies
go to meundies.com and enter code word
Joey to get 20 off of your first order
of all of their great underwear socks
t-shirts it's me on these.com Joey to
get 20 off of your first order and
shipping is always free in the US and
Canada shows also brought to you by Blue
Apron go to Blue Apron doc Blue Apron
sends Gourmet recipes and all the fresh
ingredients you need to make them right
to your door our religions get their
first two meals for free just go to
blueapron.com Joey and start cooking
incredible meals at home with blue apron
that's blue apron.com Joey and the show
is brought to you by onnit.com go to
anna.com and use code word church to get
10 off all of their great optimization
products like strong bone shroom Tech
immune and shroom Tech sport
kick that Horsley
cut that [__] out Lee kick that
[__]
[Music]
the Church of What's Happening Now
Monday May 2nd
[Music]
oh [__]
the Pete towns are ripping that
[__] up the shreds
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me or what
get the [__] syringe
[Music]
here we go
just when you thought it was safe
[Music]
[Applause]
my girl Ada Rodriguez in the house
you bad [__] listen to this
[__]
[Music]
what's the story at least I am
doing great he's doing great this
weekend you drove down the [__]
and I drove down to Dana Point to see I
have to see some of my family which is
very nice
um it's weird it's a
I when I first moved out here like I
have this some family like an hour and a
half away and I never see them and it's
it's hard when you're focusing only like
on like on like your work and other
stuff it's that sort of stuff tends to
slip at least for me so it was nice to
see them they live an hour and a half
away
at minimum in LA traffic yeah and that
that [__] people up completely that
makes your world a lot it's hard
it's really [__] hard there's people
who do it I have friends that live in
off the 210 all the way up there past
Pasadena and their family lives in
Ontario they go down there every [__]
Sunday
I would die I would [__] die
it's definitely it's uh it's rough it is
[__] Disney and people going to San
Diego and it's always [__] uh
trafficking down there so not that my
parents didn't make family important but
there are some people who are just
families everything like I never had
barbecues every weekend or it was it was
a few times a year you saw your cousins
and stuff like that it wasn't it wasn't
like an every weekend basis well the
people I'm talking about they're
Filipinos and that's all they do they
hang out with each other yep but it's
pretty you know you look at it from an
outside and you go that's [__] crazy
but you look at it from a human being
and you go you know what man I can go
for that if I died then I wouldn't even
have [__] friends like if I can get
together my family on Saturdays and
Sundays and there'll be 19 of them and
you know you wouldn't even need [__]
that many friends you'd have the circle
of family that
you uh did everything through them and
they did everything through you so it's
kind of a weird when you don't have that
you know it's and if you wanted to you
could have it because they're there
right it's just getting them all
together and getting them all enthused
but there's not like an organizer with
two or three people on the same page
it's tough It's [__] tough man yeah
we do that in Miami though when I'm home
my brothers and my sister and there's uh
significant others I don't even know
what to call them anymore we always do
everything together because we grew up
in so much dysfunction and now we just
we creating a new thing and we go we go
to the movies
Spanish people too they get together and
they you know they cook together black
people
I I tell my wife here we don't have that
yeah we don't have that and if we had it
we wouldn't want to do it like you know
what I'm saying like it's a two-edged
[__] sword like sometimes it's in
front of you and I sit there sometimes I
go wow on Sundays I should be over
friend's house barbecuing doing this and
you're like who's friend who I don't
know I don't even know who the [__]
barbecues on Sundays Steve Simone tries
to cook on Sundays
like if Steve had a big house he'd cook
everything oh yeah Steve would cook
every day every [__] day you know
it's just people who enjoy that stuff I
enjoy it but at the same time I don't
have the time right I don't have the
time I don't have the space in my house
if I had no space in my house if I could
[__] cook like my parents did it'd be
[__] on right you said something very
interesting to me a few weeks ago that I
can't stop thinking about about how I
pay for a one bedroom apartment even
though like it's if you think about it I
should be having roommates and stuff and
the thought of I would love to go like
to Steve's house or to someone's house
but the thought of having people at my
house all the time like it blew my mind
in college when I found out that people
would just knock on your your dorm room
door just to say hi I don't I don't like
that I don't know why I don't know what
it is about me but that freaks me out a
little bit well since I met you you've
been by yourself right right now there's
people listen when you're stuck
if I was single when I was single and
Bolder I had a great roommate situation
you know why because it was a [__]
nice house
and it was two men who lived together
but we didn't have the same bathrooms oh
okay I had my bathroom upstairs he had
his bathroom all the way in the basement
there was a bathroom on the second floor
in a situation like that is great when
you live with three guys and two of them
are [__] pigs yeah there comes a time
when you go no I'm not doing this [__]
no more you know there's dishes in the
sink that some people could do that
stuff and some people do it to maybe
overcome loneliness or something with
other people there as you get older I
can't I could I was always in that
environment like I wasn't cut out to be
a mingler I was a single child so my
house was my [__] playground my mind
was my playground
so when somebody's around me it's not
that they don't bother me as much as
even when they talk sometimes because my
head's somewhere else I might be
watching TV but I'm not watching TV I'm
thinking of the next [__] move I
don't give a [__] what they're doing on
TV I'm just watching the people like
it's when people start yacking to me
that gets me aggravated because
it's fine that you're there now I'm
thinking about something else like
you're thinking about something else you
didn't want to [__] be that you know
so yeah I think it's a you know I saw
cultural because my like my my dad is
the Cuban isolationist and he hated
people coming to our house so he
programmed us that it was it was just us
he was that's why we're so close
you got your you want to play with
somebody I'll be like I want to play
with my friends you have three friends
right there your two brothers and your
sisters and that was it so when people
would come knock on the door and be like
everybody be quiet nobody's home he
hated people in our house so we would
always just be locked away when you
watch the movie Goodfellas is the same
way he says that no Outsiders yes that's
really hard for people to understand
when I was growing up I grew up with a
crew of guys
if you told them you would meet him at
eight o'clock and you showed up with
somebody you're gonna have a problem
yeah
yeah like you didn't show this online
that was just that always bothered me I
always I always used to get like a
little jealous as a kid if my friend
showed up with another friend so yeah
that's weird it's weird a lot of people
don't like that when families
uh you know just right like I was raised
in the environment where there was money
guns in the house there was Santeria in
the house
so my family would say listen you really
don't want nobody in the house yeah
there's drugs in the house and there's
weapons so I was raised
I had people come over but they had to
be tight for me to have them over then
they would ask me stupid questions why
are those glasses by the door oh yeah
why is there a Saint in your living room
what's the coconut what's the coconut
doing there you know you gotta [__]
tell them and explain and yeah you know
I was telling these guys I had a six
foot Santa Lazaro in my house oh of
course a cape and a [__] gold thing
around his head with money and fruit
girls come over and they're like oh
that's a beautiful statue yeah let's go
up to the bedroom
you can't touch it you can't his eyes
were like red so you were looking in the
middle of night
you have explained it I'm not in the
mood to explain it
yes that was always I came from that
environment that your house there was
always stuff in my house
I didn't know where it was and like you
know
my dad you know my dad was one of those
dudes my stepdad was a very he didn't
trust anybody yeah that's how I grew up
he didn't trust anybody so listen that
kid that came over here I don't know
what he's thinking you left him alone in
the basement I got something down there
in the [__] basement
my grandmother was the landlady of the
building so she used to collect the
rents so as soon as somebody came to the
door she was going to get that 38
special and it was too much for people
to come over and my grandmother has her
gun in the white handkerchief it was
just too much it would be like just
don't come just just stay away yeah I I
didn't have any of that I don't know
mine was more I don't know my like I
always had someone home so that there
was that
even when I did drugs I wasn't a mingler
um like the last 10 years of me doing
blow
like the first
five or six years of me doing drugs I
did drugs with people in rooms and talk
[__] and listened to ear beatings
then over the Year got less and less and
less and less but I just partied by
myself and unless I was really horny and
I knew this chick was on I would bring
her over because if I had listened to an
airbn for five hours trying to tell me
hey she was on her period Well B she had
a boyfriend I'm gonna [__] kill you
so I would I would search them down
before they even came over you think I'm
[__] kidding I did some creepy [__]
when I was young
I remember one night this girl told me
she was on my period And I go let me
check and she's like what are you
talking about I stuck my hand and she
let me go let me check fact Checker and
I checked and I'm like okay I'll see you
tomorrow was she yeah did he pass out no
I didn't pass out I just touched the
felt like a string or something I just
went home
I was brutal brutal when I had drugs
brutal
because I didn't want you know I can't I
can have a good time by myself doing
[__] drugs I need somebody telling me
stories I don't [__] listen to that
[__] it'll ruin your high yeah with my
[__] high so what happened to you
last time you came in one thing about
this was that
listen I gotta respect you because I
have guys that I know that our main
nameless that won't come on the show why
because of the Stars oh my God this like
listen we live in an environment of such
[__] do the faith that you do when
you talk about me you do that
I love that face
oh my God they're such [__] [__]
and and all these podcasts people think
these guys are like these guys are such
[__] [__] and I heard it I heard
the rumor like three weeks ago and it is
like you know what and you came in here
you sat here for an hour and all of a
sudden you were looking at the bag of
stuff give me all those [__] things
about 35 minutes in that your eyes were
[__] up and [__] I didn't say nothing
and you left
then I called you and then I got a call
like an hour later
somebody's like would you give my mother
or some [__] I was like the kid that
came home high so whatever and the
parents you know what it is I hadn't
eaten anything the whole day I'm
hypoglycemic and I ate one of the stars
on an empty stomach so it was like
double what it would normally be because
my blood sugar had dropped speaking of w
one of the stomach no I think 725 is
enough so when I got they said I was
walking around in circles
but then I started like passing out so
they took me to the the hospital and the
doctor said I was having a continuous
panic attack so they had to give me
these shots they almost broke my wrist
though they were they were holding me
down but the funniest part is that that
my son was like they were like how often
does she do drugs and and my uh and my
son was like she doesn't do drugs and
the doctor was like sure she doesn't you
know it was like you don't have to lie
for her son how long have you been going
through this
and they should know with the rice like
a lot of people go to the hospital every
week yeah a lot for marijuana yeah from
Edibles is it because the the the
sometimes the levels are so high for
some people and it's no it's a complete
different than that it is a different it
creeps up on you and it creeps up on you
sometimes a little fast because it's
happened to me I'm nobody alive nobody
yeah it's happened to me sometimes I've
gotten a little overzealous you know in
the beginning we would eat 500
milligrams and it happened a few times
well I thought my world was going to end
yeah I just started breathing and you
eat something real fast and take your
mind off it don't give it sugar
see I didn't know anything don't give
that [__] because he'll take
sugar and start running like a
three-year-old
you know there's just so many little
things so have you ever wanted to call
the hospital though never no no if you
go to if you go to Denver
they have the recreational side and they
have the the resident side I think
that's what they call it medical medical
and the commercial side is very it's 10
milligrams right and they do that for a
reason because people go to Colorado and
they forget they're at eight thousand
six thousand I don't know what the [__]
elevation is right one of those things
and it becomes completely different guys
trust me I'm telling you yeah it's
complete unless you have
you know years of [__] experience or
you just blow through it I blow through
it but I'm not gonna lie to you I get
once a month I get something happens I'm
here with you guys and I go home and I
get [__] up the next morning I pay my
dues too I just know how to Breeze
through it okay this afternoon I was old
and I lift on the floor by 11 o'clock
I knew I wasn't going to Jujitsu and
lift on the floor and I had a bunch of
Handy Dolores
[__] edibles
and there was those chocolate things
that that 10 milligrams
and I basically opened up the thing it
was half of them I was in the computer
and I was stoned I didn't want to get up
and eat some so I took half the thing
and I just inhaled I didn't count them I
didn't care in my mind there's like
three chocolate cookies
if you know like two hours later I'll
take a nap
really I took a nap probably 45 minutes
but I felt shitty uh I felt shitty like
it came on me weird I forgot I'd eaten
it see sometimes you forget you're
eating right that's what sets you off
once it starts hitting you you think you
got [__] diabetes or yeah or some
dementia you don't know what the [__]
going on I felt like Dimensions yeah
absolutely that elevation thing is real
when I went to Big Bear we got pizza
because there was nothing there so we
got pizza and about like on the second
to last slice I was convinced I tasted
soap I was like and on the phone because
I was also High I I I I thought for some
reason that the Domino's guy was mad at
me so I was like you know what they did
they put soap on the thing and they put
it they did it on purpose because
because they thought it was rude and
Paul was like what are you talking my
girlfriend was like what you're you're
crazy you're losing it and I was like no
taste it it tastes like soap I'm not
crazy this has never happened before you
taste yourself that tastes fine
and I just I was convinced the whole
night and I think it was because the of
the elevation it's scary yeah so you
gotta add that in so they were feeding
people 100 milligrams so somebody like
hater
who had smoke pot a few times maybe
drank a few times goes to Colorado and
she hooks up with me at a comedy club we
start talking [__] and all of a sudden
she eats 100 milligrams
she's gonna go home
you know do you remember the time I went
on the road with Felicia to San
Francisco and somebody gave me a Taffy
that was like 300 milligrams and I
[__] ate it man
and I went back to the hotel I couldn't
make it to my room wow yeah and I'm a
big dude you know I've done a heroin
everything I couldn't handle it to my
room I went back to my room and puked
and
I puked on this [__] a few times one
time on Chandler with a suit on with no
shirt I was driving on Chandler with no
shirt on with suspenders in the suit and
I got out of my car on channel and just
started puking green water where was
your shirt in the car I had to take it
off I had the air on and the [__]
sunroof open with all the windows open I
was so [__] up I couldn't make the
left turn hey that ever happened to you
yeah I couldn't make a right turn either
I couldn't make a right turn let's do
what happened I pulled out of CBS
Radford I made the left
sometimes they make you park outside and
this particular day I had a meeting
inside with CBS so I had a suit up they
let me park in close to the thing when I
was in the meeting they're looking at me
and I'm [__] getting high in the
meeting and I take my job I'm like it's
hot in here and I take my jacket off
first and then they're looking I can
tell they're looking at me weird I could
tell the color in my face is leaving
yeah I could tell all this shit's
happening I'm breathing heavy I'm
stepping on the water and nothing seems
to work I feel that first sweat bead
going down my head this is CBS rapper
they got the air down to 63. some Jews
don't [__] around
[Laughter]
coming back here I forgot my [__] car
in the parking lot I had to stop before
you get to the gate with a little
Mexican seeing they have like an hour
with a Mexican dude I had a pullover
and I took the dress shirt off so now
I'm down to suspenders and a veto call
Leone wife beater that's too long so my
tit's hanging out of the side I pull up
to the window and the guy goes thank you
thank you and I make the left out of CBS
ref and I'm going to Ventura there's a
McDonald's there McDonald's Trader Joe's
okay so right away I [__] up already
because I was supposed to make a [__]
right but I couldn't decide you know
there's a street right there you can
make a right and cut to Laurel Canyon
yeah I couldn't make the right turn man
I don't make the right turn my hand
won't make the right turn so now I'm on
cold water and I won't make the right
turn I got all the way to like Fulton uh
before I made the right turn and I
finally got to Chandler and on Chandler
I had a pullover and take the wife
beater off all right now I'm driving
tits out suspenders windows down sunroof
open
music is off I can't even tolerate music
I got the air blasting
I was driving on channel in the right
hand lane maybe doing 22-23 people are
going around me beeping [__] you the
whole [__] thing I'm just holding on
to the steering wheel hater just holding
a brain to get me to Colfax so I can
make the left and go home praying
I get the call I not even not even make
it to Laurel King and I had to pull over
like a block before you know they have
like those little Jewish schools yep I
had to pull over there and puke in front
of kids people were walking by I'm just
barfing my green puke
I got back in the car I drove all the
way home I made it home
there was water in the back seat you
know like when you drink a half a thing
of water you throw in the back seat
though I took that water and drank that
hot water ah did it make you puke I
think that's what made me puke the water
sometimes sets it off for me yeah it got
made me puke and I went home and I sat
in front of the air conditioner I took
my pants off my wife came in she goes
eat that [__] again aren't you and she
[__] one in the room and that was it
done and what was it that you took that
day what was it the the banana bread the
banana bread was killing [__]
banana what happened was I ate a banana
bread and then Felicia got one
and Felicia goes what am I going to do
with it I don't want the car I don't
want in the house so I got in the car I
was gonna melt I don't want that [__] to
melt so you did it well up on me
so I get it and I've got anxiety on
planes when I didn't barf yeah I got one
time twice on a plane where I just
couldn't stop sweating
oh yeah I could every time I took my
shirt off on the plane in first class
all the way to Miami oh [__] that's a
long flight put my shirt off sweating
drinking water drying off eating
cinnamon candy the cinnamon candy Set It
Off oh wow this is the best though the
best stories you have the you should
just write a whole book about your your
highs your trip oh my God I'm sure
that'll be a great coffee table book oh
please puke and [__] often speaking of
that what was it like seeing the red
eyes of the of the statue when you were
like High
that must have been at that time I
really wasn't doing
the drugs I did a year later
but I would do THC Crystal and I
wouldn't even look at the Saints
whenever I got high I was I'm such a
Catholic I wouldn't even look at the
same you never you're not scared of them
you just feel like you're disrespecting
you're disrespected but they raise you
not you're never afraid of you you
that's here to protect you oh I know but
red eyes when you're okay what I was
thinking of was acid yeah like brown
eyes but the lighting in the living room
when you had the hallway light on with
the lights off in the living room his
eyes got [__] weird there was a
certain glass room that they made him
out of to make them look real
it was [__] creepy it was really
creepy and it would creep people out
when I brought them over the Heat and
[__] like that and it was just a certain
amount of people that would come over
and wouldn't even ask
some of my friends would come over not
ask those are the [__] that
came over all the time what's this
what's that what's this I grew up in a
place you don't ask don't ask nothing
just keep walking in the house they're
gonna feed you shut the [__] up you
start asking stupid [__] questions
and [__] what's this what's that so I
wouldn't bring them over you know and
your answer to everything is I don't
know I don't know I don't know you know
say where's your mother I don't know I
don't know what does your mother do for
a living I don't know everything I don't
know what's your phone number I don't
know it's amazing I was raised just like
that that's a different mentality to
raise your child yeah that's how it is
because we my mom figured people would
get to me to get to her and ask her
questions I remember one day that pulled
up and I was talking to a cop
and she called me I was gonna put that
what was that dude asking what did he
want why were you even talking to him
like why the [__] were you even talking
to him when I tell my wife those things
and I tell Lee Lee thinks I'm kidding
them no that's how you grow up is very I
don't know nothing you don't know
anything your teacher asked you in
school what happened at home I don't
know I don't know anything you know it's
so weird even when I watch
some of those there's an episode of
Sopranos when he has to go meet the
construction guy and the construction
guy's wearing a wire and he's asking
questions
and how he would act watch them watch
when you watch that show there's certain
times when he's talking to somebody
where they're saying something to him
that's a criminal
thing and he changes it completely
different and it blows the person out of
the water that's how I was raised to do
that stuff yeah especially when somebody
says something to you in front of other
people it was it was a lot of times I
think if I understand what you're saying
it's like if the cops bring something up
like hey were you there I went that
robbery and he goes ah nice salami
sandwich today or like just something
completely different
you just don't you're not even what
robbery I don't know what you're talking
about I don't know what you're talking
about I wouldn't even mention the
robbery yeah I don't know if people
would talk to me I would go
I think I was eating pizza Tuesday and
they would [__] just look at me
like what the [__] yeah and my wife
doesn't understand that it's okay to
tell people you don't know even if they
know that you know yeah
I don't give a [__] if you know that I
know I'm still not going to tell you
that's right even though you know I know
I don't know what you're talking about
it's better to say you don't know
because you then nobody can quote you
that's what my mommy said nobody's gonna
say Ida said this and either said that
so it's better for you to say I don't
know no Los siento I don't know that's
how we were raised because no matter who
you whose house you were raised in every
one of us grew up where there's
something illegal illegal yeah
absolutely well you don't know I don't
know I don't know yeah well you know
what time your mom gonna tell no no what
time she got well yesterday I don't know
I was at my grandmother you just drive
me crazy yep that's a crazy way so when
does that stop though it never does I
still do it today I don't know what
people are talking yeah I have no idea
what you're talking about it doesn't I
could change a conversation within a
second you do it sometimes like a second
I don't know what you're talking about
how do you want to discuss that so let's
change it especially if you bring it up
in front of somebody yeah like that's
not supposed to be in the room I don't
know what you're [__] talking about
yeah it is it doesn't go away it doesn't
go away I was raised like that and the
funny thing was
the people I was raised with were raised
at the animals like that
so everybody knew the rules you don't
know nothing
yeah but you were right there you were
standing there no but I was looking down
there what happens it's like I don't
know someone just moves into a new town
like would people like systematically
try to get them out like your town
specifically seems like there's a lot of
similar people there
like so okay North America for example
I'll tell you a real quick story about
North Bergen my friend George
my friend George has lived in North
Bergen for 20 years his kids have gone
to that school
until this day George says to me it's
like I'm on the [__] outsider because
to them you are an outsider you didn't
play football with them you didn't play
Little League baseball with them
and you're definitely didn't go to
Grandma's school with them they have no
idea who the [__] you are even if they
know who you are
it's tremendous there's no talk to you
they'll communicate this you know
they're not bad people
you're just an outsider you'll always be
an outsider yeah and you feel it
eventually you feeling okay and you have
two decisions to make to keep dealing
with these people or just
being outside into that Circle and
that's fine that's fine that's some
people just maybe it's better for you
not to be involved with what they're
doing Sunday something happens you're
like damn see that worked out but it's
it's uh
my wife doesn't understand that at no
level she's like well people people I
don't give a [__] what people think
I don't you don't need to say nothing to
nobody you know I told you yesterday I
was in the balcony
smoking the people across the street
from me
the the the the painted chick and the
[__] drunk and the two uh and the two
[__] uh the two [__] whatever the
[__] they are transgenders and the new
chartist chick were across the street
barbecuing and I said to myself you know
what they've never invited us over there
like how many times have I walked over
and said hello
you know it's so weird I keep my
neighbor's arm's distance yeah because
the enemies once you invite them in
that's it they come over every day when
even when you want to be there or not do
you have to talk to them
so before you open your [__] mouth
you know it's a situation when lady next
to me told my wife a bunch of [__] now
she went back with the guy so I tell my
wife all the time you see why you don't
spread your business no way about people
whatever goes on your house where you
and your wife or your wife nobody knows
nothing that's right I don't know
nothing I don't know [__] nothing you
know what I'm saying it's
but there's people who uh
think that they have to [__] talk
tell you their whole [__] life story
in eight [__] minutes that drives me
crazy you you know I'm a week and
they're telling you they got molested
yeah you got a little me for 10 years
before I tell you I gotta finger up the
ass never mind molested you know they're
telling you that life [__] story you
sit there and go how [__] pathetic
are you you're telling me your life
[__] story yeah
so in those neighborhoods no this is the
way of life
the least you say
the better off you are
because everything you say is going to
be analyzed if you're an outsider yeah
so you smile you say hello and you and
you speak when you're spoken to
so now that you're raising a kid in like
popular cultures the exact opposite of
that how does that make you feel
I will definitely raise Mercy you know I
was raised in that statue
you don't know nothing don't open the
door for nobody ask my mom's not home
call back later if you answer the phone
I don't know you have to call back I
don't know I don't know because all
those little things
they're little [__] things it's a
cold we had a code I don't want you
discussing what happens in this house at
the school ever you don't know nothing
what's your dad do I don't know where
does he go to work I don't know
is he there when you leave I don't know
he's somewhere was he there now I don't
know
just to every question will he be that
among I don't know and eventually they
just put their hands on their hips and
they know a [__] time it is yep
they know what [__] time is
and then you talk to her and you tell
her don't let them scare you just stick
to your [__] story they're lying to
you
you know I'm gonna tell her all that
[__] those are the evils of the world
that my wife was never told
that's why when a cop pulls up my wife
will tell them anything you know she
don't [__] know
she don't [__] know nothing you turn
your back I don't know that
but why Joey because you don't [__]
know none everything you say You're
Gonna incriminate yourself yep so why
are you saying something to these
[__] people
you know Neighbors
you know like yesterday again I feel bad
because I should be mingling with people
but there's a good side to that and
there's a bad side to that and I'm 53
with a baby and a wife I don't want
nobody coming home my [__] house
either yeah so I don't I don't want
people mingling on my doorstep borrowing
sugar
you know one that I go in the living
room and the [__] not the lesbian but
the [__] transgender is in my living
room I swear to God not in my living
room but in my backyard trying to
capture a skunk no I said listen let me
ask you something when I get up to go on
the road at four in the morning that
skunks in that box you're gonna take it
out of the box do me a favor get that
[__] box out of here they didn't talk
to me for six months
because they put a box in your yard yeah
so after that they knew what time it was
like one day the one transgender it's a
nice day and then nice people
but the one guy wanted to be friendly
like a little too friendly with my wife
like you you have a better chance of
being friendly with me
because my wife don't buy into none of
that [__] at least I grew up around it
I've talked to a young son it's a goof
for me he put his hand on the car while
my wife was opening up the car door to
take the baby out he was waiting and I
turned and I saw this and I'm like oh
this is not gonna be any good
my wife slammed I don't know I said do
you [__] mind
you know because he was coming over
going hey any shows lately he'll even
tell me this every [__] day he would
say yummy shows in town yeah tonight at
the comedy store and they wouldn't show
what do you keep asking me for that's
right I'm one of those [__] guys you
know after the third time you don't show
stop asking me stop [__] bothering me
all right
and that's what happened after that they
knew what time it was they never [__]
with us again now it's a hi goodbye how
are the cats good I saw this Kathy all
night this cat died that's it we keep it
about the cats
laughs
it's like it's weird like I I don't know
if I told you but I had a neighbor once
just like Saturday morning at 9am just
knock on the door and ask me for a ride
to somewhere on like where yeah Four
Mile yeah to like four miles away
because her car got towed and luckily
Paula was there so I was like what do
you no I'm like this people have weird
stuff like with that like asking
neighbors I don't I don't I don't talk
to any of my neighbors me either
no my dad used to be like they come and
they ask you for a cup of sugar and then
the next day the temperature
that's what my dad was saying what she
just said was one day they asked you for
sugar the next day knock on the door
they want your [__]
true
[__] true he
was true and I ran into that in Colorado
when I moved to Colorado I was a young
kid I wanted to be everybody's [__]
friend I wanted to be light next thing
you know I got four people in my living
room smoking my reefer every night and
nobody's showing up not even with a hot
dog bun empty
you know and I tell you the story about
the Kentucky that's why I robbed them he
was right upstairs and I just robbed him
he kept coming down man somebody robbed
my house last night
and I got the fingerprints on this
Scotch tape
I'm out of my face you got fingerprints
on my Scotch tape
you're saying I'm over here loading up a
[__] bowl of that you show up with
fingerprints on this kind of thing
all right so how long did you stay at
the hospital for oh I was only there for
like six hours oh Jesus Christ they had
to put Ivy because they said I was
dehydrated my heart rate dropped it was
it dropped yeah it was a it was a whole
it was a whole Fiasco it was a scene I'm
actually writing it as an episode of my
TV show because it was really funny
um my kids had to come get me from the
in and out because I couldn't drive
anymore it was so high I couldn't even
next to the old office yeah they came
and got me I pulled over and then I was
like can you give me a burger no that's
why I ended up in the hospital because I
hadn't eaten and my blood sugar just
dropped it was it was funny I was there
for six hours and then I believe they
tried to break my wrist I could hear
them talking about
um me being a drug addict and then um so
they were gonna break your wrist no they
were trying to break my wrist to put
needle uh to give me these shots but
they were holding me down but they were
holding me hard and I was like I'm hi
I'm not dead I can feel this like your
whole it hurts and um my wrist was
swollen for two weeks
two weeks it was uh it was a fiasco it
was so funny kids call what'd you give
her what you doing I was walking around
in a circle oh my God
they said I was walking around in
circles and I kept doing my hair like
this
[Laughter]
do you remember any of what you were
thinking during this time um I was
hoping that um I didn't lose my mind
permanently how was your breathing how
was your heart did you feel yeah it was
I was I was gone and then you feel the
breathing was bad you couldn't even yeah
I was having a problem this got tight it
was just hilarious
it was funny though because it was an
experience to write about and then
afterwards sometimes you got to get
humbled you know what I mean I believe
like you walk around you know I don't do
I don't really do drugs I don't drink
like that I'm pretty uptight I'm always
stressed out a very Latin always worried
about with but what about next month and
what about so I needed that Mo that just
it just slowed me down because during
that time I was on edge on super Edge
and it just calmed me down for like two
days I went to sleep for like two days I
hadn't slept because I'm an insomniac I
don't sleep so I that I got two whole
nights of sleep that because of it so it
was I'm an optimist I was I looked at it
as a blessing how do they sober you up
they they hold you down they tie you up
it's terrible they give you the
anti-anxiety medication which is a pill
or a shot and what do you feel like they
just get you high yeah no they it
relaxes you your heart just calms down
and then they give you fluids
and then they keep you there until they
think it's ready you're ready to go home
did they ask you what you took
um I just told them I ate something and
I don't know what it was
you know what you know what I was saying
right I don't know I don't know
who gave it to you I don't know
and then he turned to my son because I
was so high and he was like who gave her
the drugs and he was like I don't know
because I raised him like that so he was
like they were like you guys are not
gonna give us any answer her well-being
and my son was like I told you what I
needed to tell you she had it inedible
it was uh she had a bad reaction to it
what are you gonna do this is this the
hospital or the police station and the
lady was like looking at him like what
and my son was like take care of her
that's what we're here for we're not
here to answer your question crazy yeah
he was [__] crazy red man called the
ambulance on himself yeah twice
to get the ambulance set to the 101 he
pulled over the [__] car dog I know
Hey listen man I feel my heart sometimes
I would go to the gym sometimes on those
Stars
and you get deep and you know and all of
a sudden the gym is Big so your hearing
starts to go oh yeah you're hearing I
can't believe you do it at the gym
that's crazy I didn't know either I
would need three of those stars and go
to the [__] YMCA
get on the treadmill get on the
treadmill the bicycle oh my God
oh my God that one boy in that workout
you run out of oxygen you're like all of
a sudden that [__] star takes you to
a different [__] place of anxiety
yeah it does it was it was interesting
but still you know uh you know you've
been through so much in life and
something like something happens and
you're like oh really like the SWAT team
came to my house when I was little like
there's nothing that could shock you
with this [__] oh like I I mean
people are like oh my God you know and
I'm like really like I've seen I've seen
really horrific things that's nothing
it's crazy what
some people's perception of bad is yeah
like Lee Lee's a great kid Lee's never
seen a bug get hit like we see stuff and
he gets all you're not gonna believe Lee
Lee relax don't give a [__]
he gets all emotional red in the face he
called me something did you change the
passcode because I can't get her
completely yeah I changed the passcode
a few months I don't know you know it's
just
but it's it it's going back the way I
was brought up like that was right I was
walking down the street today just now
on the way here
and there's three dudes in front of me
they gotta be about 22. the
skateboarding uh you know jumping up and
down they got tattoos the whole thing
as they got to this house over here I'm
looking straight ahead
and I heard a dog bark and all three of
them jumped in the air and I kept
walking and I said and I didn't know why
I just didn't know why
like all three of them jumped on the
[__] the dog was two feet big you
know two feet high I'm sorry
you know I I just kept walking right and
I remember going Jesus Christ really I
don't even react to dogs anymore yeah
it's it's a
light my upbringing I'm sure that hey
this upbringing at times you think of it
isn't as sad and uh
it sometimes I think of my life at home
my mom especially now that you riding
all this stuff yeah and you get stuck on
how am I gonna write that section you
think about the section from a different
point of view
and you think about your life from a
different point of view and it the
realities are realities you know what at
points in my life it was very sad how my
mom raised me yeah and it was very sad
the things she showed me at an early age
because it takes away your childhood
yeah you're always paranoid even knowing
about things like listen when you're
eight and you know about eating [__]
yeah that makes you look at Barbie a lot
[__] different yeah I think and a lot
different you're not supposed to even
hear about eating [__] and [__] I
didn't hear it at home and you heard on
the streets of New York City hey go get
your dick sucked then you start asking
questions who sucks your dick and then
people tell your girl suck your dick and
now you know you're seven years old you
know people just be sucking your dick I
didn't want to know that at seven yeah I
didn't want to know that seven it was
things like that I can't blame it all
seven is crazy I can't blame it all on
my mother in the bar I have to blame it
on the where I was raised at the time
this country the time in this country
was completely [__] different you
know
but then you look at the other side of
it
today I'm getting the proposal ready for
the book and I'm up to the chapter now
where it's a month before she dies and a
month before my mother died the house
was very sad she lost a bar and her and
her husband got separated and she still
had money and she was still living her
life but the house was different and I
was the man of the house
but I was the man in the house I didn't
have to pay bills I didn't have to mow
the lawn it was like I was different man
I had to keep her together right you
learned like keep a woman together and I
was saying she learned to like keep you
together and I think about how I used to
come home at night like I remember I
went to my mom one day like oh Mom
where's those jeans and she goes I
didn't wash them and I like made like a
noise and she goes
what
stop washing your own clothes
by the time I was like 12
or 11 I was already washing my own
clothes and hanging them up yeah you
know I had a bathroom and
I was a [__] uh uh I didn't like
people peeing in my bathroom yeah so
somebody came home and had some people
and I left I went up there with [__]
fantastic yeah and then wiped the toilet
seat and I cleaned my bathroom my
bathroom was that was my [__]
bathroom yep and she used to say to me I
like that you keep your bathroom clean
you know in those days I used to not
wash my clothes I used to fold them my
mom would go hey you want 20 bucks
tonight yeah do your favor you gotta go
pay the mortgage today and go pay the
phone bill on those days you didn't
write a check okay you had to go stand
online and pay your phone bill online to
pay your phone bill might take an hour
it might take 10 minutes
you know what I'm saying then from there
had to walk two mother miles to go pay
the mortgage
so I tell people there's times I think
that she was preparing me for her to die
and this times I think that you know in
those days my mom would go hey man I get
home at six from hustling that there may
not be no dishes in the sink and that
[__] house better be vacuumed that
was part of what I did you know what I'm
saying yeah those little things they
took the garbage out
get it away it prepared me for
uh
you know when I from the time I was
[__] eighth I didn't leave my dishes
on the table the time I was a kid they'd
bring me
she wouldn't even bring it to me I
remember still after school I would go
in my room get my notebooks out and she
would yell for me and I'd come in and
get my little swiss cheese with America
with ham and toast and mayonnaise and
some iced tea with lemons and [__] and
I'd bring it into my room then I had to
bring my dish
and my [__] cut back you know what
I'm saying like I had to do all these
little things where I would [__] get
it was like she was Preparing Me For
Life For Life absolutely and I grew up
paranoia too but I'm so thankful that my
mom put that that and my dad put that in
me because when I look at my friends I
was like you [__] would all get
kidnapped I would never get because of
the way that I was schooled I was
walking down the street the other day
and this dude was that was walking
behind me and I stopped until he walked
around me and my girlfriend was like why
did you do that I said because we have
somebody behind us that we don't know he
can just hit us from the back and she
was like you're paranoid I'm like yeah
you you know you'll end up on a milk
carton it's not that I'm paranoid is
that you know the realities of Life yeah
you know how they end up Lee came to me
one day he goes hey man I'm thinking of
getting a bicycle that's great or we
can't talk about it oh no no no no no we
can't of course oh I think you're going
like this no there was just another
story of someone getting killed again
where uh here in L.A I can't remember
the intersection right now but it was
just all like like I think someone a car
and the car hit the bike or something
like they have it all the time yeah he
told me he came when they get a bike I
love Lee I wanted to get healthy but you
know what man and that way a bike
and like listen man I used to go to yoga
with my wife way before Mercy came right
here at the Y write down the court and
one day guess what we meet in front of
us are you human from Miami but she
speaks Cuban fluent you know her mom's
Cuban really got her dad's Jewish the
whole thing one day I see we're leaving
yoga on a Thursday night at 8 30 and
this [__] got a helmet and I looked at
him and I said what's the helmet for and
she goes I ride my bike home I go where
do you live she goes on cold water and
whatever go listen man
why don't you call your husband why
don't you give me a [__] ride leave
the bike here I said that to her and she
goes no I like riding my bike do you
know the next time we've seen that [__]
had a false tooth and stitches she got
hit by a bike and dragged she sued the
guy they had to put a fox tooth in their
mouth with [__] stitches and [__] and
she was like you were right no [__] up
right you don't ever want to ride a
bicycle [__] L.A I'm scared to walk
no it's dangerous I walk my baby to
school every day and pick her up in the
car but I walk them
because the train station's close by and
I know what comes off this train and I
see it sometimes I'd go for a ride at
eight and I see people looking the same
way
I used to look when I was trying to make
something happen
people understand that I was one of
those guys that if I had a dollar in my
pocket or 200
I got up at eight and I went for a walk
just to see what you can make happen
you never know
I see a girl I follow I didn't know
there was an office on the corner I go
in that office it's a building with 52
offices
and all those doors are open and I could
knock on one of those doors and say is
Miriam here
there ain't no Miriam here okay
but if I walk in and you're in your
bathroom break I would open the desk
take the petty cash and take your wallet
out of your purse
and I would go one of those a day just
for walking
but the same way
I could have broke into an office it's
the same way I see my wife walking with
the baby and I see my wife with that
stupid person I always tell her why do
you bring that [__] personal
I go where you going so I'm walking the
kid to school all you need is your
[__] a 20 Bill to get coffee over
there and again I see it go in the
person get her ID why are you taking
your ID out of your [__] address on
it why put the [__] she looks at me
like what if a cop stopped me what if
tell him to follow you home you got your
wallet over at the [__] house leave
the ID there in case you pull the 20 on
the ID flies out now you're [__] don't
take your ID out of your [__] wallet
ever ever does it come out of your wall
that's right I take it out the fly I put
it back in there those people that leave
it with the [__] ticket I see them
dropping their IDs all the time at the
airport for every three times I go to
the airport I see a [__] idea on the
floor and I see them going on my ID and
I leave it there I don't even say them
[__] for being stupid now you'll
[__] learn not to be [__] stupid
after that I don't care if there's 200
people waiting behind me I put my ID
back in the [__] wallet and as I'm
walking down the security line that's
when I go back in I take it out again I
don't walk through the airport when I be
[__] loose you lose your [__] idea
in there but within hours you're [__]
all five thousand dollars in Africa yeah
you know what I'm saying within hours
you lose your [__] at the airport are
you [__] nuts there's little things
it's not called paranoia
there's little [__] things just to
avoid a world of hurt yeah I've never
lost my ID since I well knock on wood
you know knock on wood don't say that
[__] that's right but you know but it's
because in my mind my my dad would
always be like that has your address on
it that's where you lay your head every
and wherever you let that go you don't
know what kind of
Elemento always used to tell me that so
he my the idea is sacred you don't walk
around I don't leave my house with my ID
sometimes because of that there's a lot
of people who want put their home
address in their phone no mine because
if someone gets your phone or your UPS
then they know where you live let me
tell you something yeah let me tell you
something off the bat you and Ada this
[__] phone
you're dead as soon as you have this
phone
you're dead
once you pay your bills online and use
your credit card to buy music oh you're
dead oh yeah you're half dead yeah you
have that you're already you're already
dead there's no security in this they
can tap this from anywhere they can
listen in on your conversations and
within five minutes have all your
[__] information and start [__]
[__] with your world this this is the
worst thing in the world right here yeah
not only this it tells people where the
[__] you are at every minute that's good
and [__] bad okay that's good and
[__] bad in my world where I come
from that's communism yep that's
communism in my world that's kind of
that's the beginnings of communism
in an inadvertently way
I see so many things going into I think
in a hundred years will all be the same
[__] people yeah same tattoos with
numbers on them you can pay for your
bills with your hand
everything will be on computer but the
most important thing is that you always
be accountable for even your thoughts
even your thoughts it was really I went
to the Apple store the other day and as
I walked in I have an Apple gift card
and it popped up on my phone
so that like yeah you're they're already
still I don't think it's gonna take 100
years
no I'm talking about
the Technology's way ahead of itself
it's the people right thought process of
the Americans as soon as I started
seeing people I swear to God as soon as
I seen people started getting the
tattoos
I'm like we're in trouble because we're
all like-minded now
you had a tattoo when you were a felon
when you were a sailor man you know what
I'm saying you had a tattoo when you
were outside the realm
normal Housewives didn't have tattoos
I'm at the airport I see a mom with of
two babies and she's got tattoos on her
[__] feet
okay you know that wasn't around 30
[__] years ago
I see that the tattoo is the beginning
until the humans will put your address
on your [__] arm or what they did in
Nazi Germany and people might think I'm
[__] or crazy for saying something
like that that's what I see I see them I
see you being accountable
all the way through from A to Z these
computers these computers they read your
emails
what you listen to what you like in
other words your thoughts your feelings
your emotions
the music you play every time I click on
YouTube Every time I click on [__]
Facebook every time you click you say
something on Twitter every [__] email
that you write to your mom when you
write to your girlfriend you want to
suck her [__] or when you write to
somebody you know this is your idea for
[__] life all that [__] is out there
all that shit's out there somebody's
reading your stuff right now you have to
assume
you have to assume
you have to assume on every level and
and not to mention the the hours we have
now of
our entire lives on the internet
so people could very easily
create false identities no it's it's the
least of your problems is false identity
that's the least of your problems
they do it all the time the less the
least of your worries is false identity
you don't even see where I'm going with
this one with the government I see that
yeah I'm not even seeing this at the
government
seeing this within us
we're all becoming we all want to be the
same person
we all want to drink the same coffee you
know it's the caste system not the caste
system there's some people who can't
afford a four dollar cup of coffee and
they make coffee at the house these
people go to a place to be recognized to
be social so people know that they go to
Starbucks that brand oh my God I love
Starbucks and they you know it's it's
it's it's just everything Lee I see it I
I you know they're making you pay this
much for tickets these phones the GPS
even in your cars they have all your
emotions you know I mean uh your wife
could monitor you anybody can mod you I
don't give a [__] if my wife want to
monitors me that I don't do dick anyway
I hang out with you I go to the ATM
machine I go to [__] Jiu Jitsu what
the [__]
but just to thought that somebody knows
where I am
through my [__] phone if I have it in
my pocket
just a thought that they could listen to
your conversations which they've been
listening to for 2 000 [__] years but
it was a lot to eat a lot harder to
access those [__] wires and the
phones that are break into your house
and tap now they just cut well they've
been cutting into your wires also but it
was very old school not like they're
doing it now off satellites and [__] I'm
not like a big conspiracy theory person
but when you think about it if you look
look at that do you if there's any part
of you think maybe the government made
these and said give give these to people
and maybe they'll give us
every single act like information about
their life like for free like what is
that we're they're gonna pay us to give
us their information well it's not even
information it's your thoughts
it's your text messages it's your like I
said everything you're involved with is
right now 99 of what you're involved in
what you like you you uh connect with
through the computer 100 100 it's for
the purpose of control not um not they
don't want to read their emails they
just we're becoming cattle like the New
World Order is setting in and we're
gonna be numbers
and they're gonna put chips in the
children and this is a there's a book
called uh The Pale Horse Behold The Pale
Horse or something like that that talks
about a former CIA agent telling all of
the things that are gonna happen that um
are gonna make us all controllable
and the rich will be the people that get
everything and the poor people will
suffer and slavery will be back and this
will be a different type of slavery in
100 Years it'll be a different [__]
world yeah there's times I feel bad for
mercy I really feel bad for my daughter
what could happen in this country in the
next 10 years you know what could how
many people are slipping in here every
day through Mexico Canada even if just
one come in and set one thing in Iowa
then one comes in and sets another thing
in Nebraska
once they eat us from within
that'd be the smart move
if I was [__] uh Isis I would stop
right now
I'd stop and disappear
let everybody think we were done
and everything starts sending troops in
here
send them through Miami
one side of Canada the other side of the
Canada in Mexico
and put them all to a state open up a
business set them up
and one day all 20 of those States they
blow something up at the same time that
that's that's a war right there
and that could happen yeah
I could not yeah that's good but that
could happen with any group could do
that you know I thought when the FBI did
that thing a couple of weeks ago that
they couldn't get into the phone I was
starting to write a joke about it and I
go why am I random joke about it they're
the ones that write the joke right now
they know exactly how to get into that
[__] yeah they're already in the
phone they were already in the phone
with the [__] with apple I'm like
that's the FBI dog they've been getting
into people's thoughts for 200 [__]
years you don't think they can hack an
FBI phone that's what they're letting
the consumer thing oh my god well the
FBI come back how could I you know what
I'm saying like every [__] up a smart
white dude right now at home is like you
know the FBI couldn't act as well can
you imagine that that's the security of
Apple Apple's at home polishing their
fingers they look at us they don't give
a [__] idiot they're watching the guy
from Apple jerk off in this [__]
office on top of the secretary's face
they'll watch them go look at this
[__] [__] you don't think we get to
open up a phone are you [__] [__]
and then when you did you see when they
were like um we got it we got it yeah
everybody get the [__] out of it they
put an ad for these [__] idiots now
all these idiots raise their hands now
they know about them now you're on paper
that you raised your hand so you were
going to really open up the [__]
headphone you [__] [__] how they got
you on paper you want to then said my
name is Joe Smith I'll hack that phone
you [__] dummies really okay thank
you we'll call you in a week
where's Tony Bennett [__] you're
on the list unbelievable man
unbelievable what we fall for and how
gullible we are at times
[Music]
I wanna be around oh yeah to do another
star with leaves
when somebody breaks your home let's go
crazy
you already gotta split oh [__]
murder was the case that they gave me at
least going to the hospital yeah what
hospital did he go to Sherman Oaks
Hospital
they almost broke my wrist
lately it's Monday the 2nd of May if you
don't send an example who's gonna do
leave the music
[Music]
oh [__] like a doctor will you do it I
think I missed it where'd it go sorry
huh
[Music]
are you scared no I'm not scared but I
had 7 25 I just what's that butcher 850.
bam
if the puzzle fits
you wanna split one in no no no I even
brought the vapor pen if he's on
anti-fucking THC pills uh she already
ate charcoal
oh God
see what happens you eat it see what
happens when you join the Marines
these are the Marines
it's a life of fun an adventure I get to
see the world yeah you go home you don't
know what we're gonna eat right you
might end up at the cactus you might end
up at Denny's that's the world
you're gonna end up with a taco stand
what time is your favorite Taco Stand
close
uh the late the latest ones open till
midnight
so I don't think I'm gonna make that one
we'll get Johnny away before that we got
another stuff no there's no way there's
no way
how many have you had today uh
125. here we go here we go [__] it oh my
God
happy times
Charles Brunson do you know that I saw
all the Charles Brunson movies when I
was a little girl like death wish death
wish one with my grandmother like I'm
talking about five years old
Watching Death Wish
I went to see Death Wish in a movie
theater so how old are you then I was
going to be 39 39 so I'm 53.
so you're a little older than six not
bullshitting me and [__] cause no I was
serious did you see Charles Brice in the
movie theater for Death Wish no I didn't
see it in the movie theater I saw it on
HBO
yeah not in the movie theater but my
grandmother used to watch those movies
she used to idolize him she used to
think like she was one of those I-49
tooth for a tooth people so Charles
Bronson was the hero because remember
when the gang people were wreak havoc
havoc in the neighborhood see if you
could find Death Wish rape scene oh my
God it was one of the most traumatizing
rape scenes on the mattress on the floor
oh my I don't know whether and it was
Eric Globe
definitely get kicked off
that's when I'll discover
that revenge is sweet you went to see it
in the movies I was at 10 years old you
were little I was little I went to see
that I went to see Stone killer in the
movie theater I went to see the mechanic
in the movie theater I saw
the the Clint Eastwood ones when he was
a cop and the one when he took the 44
magnum I'll never forget this I went
with pepeco
if your name is Jose and Cuban then your
nickname is fell off a roof and he
[__] up his leg so he had a limp so he
called him Pepe
all right so
we went to see that movie
and uh when he this one scene when he
goes back into the coffee shop and he
goes
I've been coming here every day
Dirty Harry
coffee shop because they're not gonna
have the rape scene here oh there's none
of these all right no no
no go to uh
Dirty Harry coffee what's the death wish
is that right
coffee shop scene blast I've been coming
in here every day yeah that's it gotta
watch this this is tremendously well you
have never seen this either it's
embarrassing but
look at this [__] Savage
first time I saw this my head almost
exploded
she's just pouring coffee in this
[__]
she's just pouring sugar in his coffee
what year is this leave when Dirty Harry
came on I'll have to look it up after I
think it's 73.74
now I'm a [__] kid
and I'm watching this in New York City
on 42nd Street
don't worry about that Lee pay attention
here
all right folks you did real good with
that cop now I want everything money
watches Rings everything
quick move you're coming with me Mom
we're gonna have us a little party huh
that's why they talked to the 70s
sucker
big head sucker
every day for the last 10 years Loretta
there has been giving me a large black
coffee
today she gives me a large black coffee
only let's get sugar
you're back to complain
how you boys put those guns down
say what
whoa we're not just gonna let you walk
out of here
we sucker
Smith and Wesson
thank you
she's allowed to go home and watch this
today
he's so badass in this
so right here after the third black guy
went down Pepe Coho decides to yell
[Laughter]
sorry about that Lee you missed the line
he goes go ahead and make my dad that is
a famous [__] lie so at this that he
yells at the movie theater
that means holy [__] they're killing a
lot of black people
[Music]
foreign
we don't have these type of movies we
don't have an American hero no we have
superheroes and that's what people
misunderstood me a couple weeks ago when
I was saying I don't like [__]
superhero movies
because now we're good we they don't do
nothing they don't do nothing we
identify with [__] superheroes
there's no [__] superheroes nobody's
got a [__] Cape nobody's gotta
nobody's a [__] Iron Man we identify
with men growing up you know Charles
Bronson was a huge piece of me you know
anything about me is I got an extra
Revenge
a cell whatever the gene yeah so all
those movies were about people you know
they were doing something wrong but at
the same time in their world they were
doing something right you know
I've always believed like I have all
those things in my mind people I want to
stab
like I'm pissed in a way that things
worked out in calmly because I couldn't
kill my wife you know what I'm saying if
things wouldn't have worked out in
County right now I'd be doing 20 years
and she'd be somewhere looking like
Nicole Simpson when the missing [__]
head somewhere you know what I'm saying
but things things work looking like
Nicole yeah oh cool I'm saying I'm sorry
but it's the truth you know when I first
came to L.A I came to LA to kill time my
my thing was to kill time I knew I
wasn't gonna ever do nothing comically I
was going to be an extra so I was just
totally killed time until I could go
back and figure out how I was gonna stab
my ex-wife and a [__] husband that
was the truth in my heart guys in my
heart that was the truth
and I kept getting less and less and
over the years and now my daughter don't
talk to me and I'd be honest I still
want to stab him up with those
[__] like every time I go to
Denver I don't even think about going to
boat I stay in my hotel room I
because I know if something bad happens
I'll take that train to [__] devil
one of those rainbow knives to Boulder
and I'll wait for her in the bushes I
don't want to do that
I don't want to do that I don't want to
do that we don't want you to do that no
no no no I'm too old for that [__] so
it's weird like
so I have that extra you know that extra
type of when somebody [__] with you a
lot you give them you let them forget
about it and then you go get them let
him thinks that everything's beautiful
and then you [__] show up you know
what I'm saying sometimes they even
worry about me I go what about the
people I [__] with 30 years ago maybe
they're laying in a bush waiting for me
somewhere you know what I'm saying you
never know that's why you always gotta
have new chunks in the [__]
it's amazing whatever the [__] they have
man oh you got nunchucks no I got no
[__] what the new check's gonna do
for your head-to-hand comment at this
age I'll tell you what you got one good
swing dog I hate getting the hell with a
[__] new Chuck one of those
regulation ones yeah it's gonna be like
blue one dog you're gonna have a
concussion You're Gonna Hear Voices for
a couple weeks I have one of those
Louisville Sluggers in my car oh yeah
you gotta have one of them bust somebody
in the head really hard with them you
gotta get a hanger
and you uh
tape at the end electrical tape
if they catch you it's like an illegal
weapon but boy
that [__] about birds at night people
don't see it coming they don't see it
they just hear
this [__] hit me with no new
jokes it's [__] crazy the street
weapons you can have
it's always nice when you're in here
because it reminds me of home I know I'm
not crazy and I don't know if it's the
Spanish side of us that grew up with
this craziness and uh you know crazy
people in your life that sometimes
you're too embarrassed to tell people
about the craziness in your life as a
youth yes but sometimes like when I met
you you would tell me all these stories
I would just giggle by your father and
[__] I would just giggle
because part of those stories of who I
am it's me yeah I giggle and I get
scared I tell my wife when I came home I
told her about all the [__] things
your dad would do to you I'm like you
know what the scary thing is that's me
yeah I think about the same way with
daughters you know you have to be a firm
and I told you I had two friends
two Cuban girls that I grew up with that
Dad stopped talking to
stop talking to him one because he told
the mother not to let her wear those
shorts shorts
because she couldn't come back here and
break when I'm gonna [__] get the
[__] out of here and the other one lived
downstairs and I forget what she did she
just dated or something and he stopped
talking to him
what's up with you Lee that that
milligram hit you yeah [__] okay
yeah I'm pretty sure it's everything
save me I'm doing good
this is a tough week for a lot of people
uh
Lee talked about it last week that he
wanted to go visit his mom and I said
you know busting his balls
huh I was what's that no I'm listening
oh you scratching one of those scrub
dads in your [__] that
my dreads dreads whatever the [__] first
thing you said when you came in and
they're really cornrows quad dreads I
don't [__]
this is a [__] up week for me and
especially since I was writing about it
today
uh you know it's Mother's Day you know
and uh lee was saying last week and when
I went back to the house that I'm like I
can't believe Lee was letting me bust
his balls by going to visit his mom I
got it but just how he was stoned and he
said to me because I haven't seen my mom
I did not say Mom I did not I would not
say mommy in front of you
so it's just uh
and it's funny how you it's her birthday
it's my mom's birthday on the night it's
my mom's birthday May 9th and May 9th is
the day my godmother died my favorite
one of my favorite ladies in the world
by Santeria godmother
so uh
I was thinking man and listen I talked
to you yeah and you said you're doing
this Mother's Day benefit you're taking
35 homeless mothers I know where'd you
meet these homeless mothers I haven't
met him um I found them through this
organization I'm gonna take them to
breakfast on Saturday and Sunday Felicia
Lori kill Martin and Tiffany haddish and
I are gonna do a comedy show for them at
the Improv on Sunday on Mother's Day
yeah you know I miss my mom too and you
know no my mom is alive but my mom's
been an addict for many years so it's
not like she's been here where she lives
Miami okay so
um why do if you're addicted you got to
move out of Miami oh Florida is it's
[__] yeah I never
for years Lee before you were even
around or a fan of football
we had a [__] horrible football
player that had drug problem like me his
name is Hollywood Anderson
okay Hollywood Henderson was drafted
tremendous linebacker one of [__]
whatever got fired
guess who picked him up
Miami Dolphins
he lasted a month a month he got he got
fired from Miami for smoking a joint
with his daughters
okay hilarious honey and when they
interviewed him until he's like hey I
smoked the [__] joint with this door
this one you know he was just crazy [__]
there was another guy he was the
fridge's brother
what's the fridge Perry yeah his brother
he had a brother that played for the
Broncos
six DUIs cocaine who do you think
[__] they traded him to [__] Miami
Miami is the last place you want to go
yeah if you have a sex addiction a Coke
addiction a booze addiction any pill
addiction that's the [__] capital of
pills absolutely it's like the last
place you want to be I can't imagine
being an addict in Miami and being stuck
in that cycle yeah that cycle of just
trying to make rent and trying to
[__] keep your [__] drug and have
it alive
that's why I don't live there anymore I
am very lucky when I wake up every
morning talk you have no idea how many
people I think on the way to piss
and I think one of the biggest thanks I
have is that I don't have to go find the
drug deal at eight o'clock every night
anymore yeah
that's something to be thankful for
Jesus Christ I had [__] call for your
trash grow up last week and I told him I
go you know over the years I see all the
things that were happening to me leading
up to me quitting
and they were all pointing at a [__]
Dino how to take my spine was starting
to hurt
towards the end when having a quarter
gram of coke left I would get shocks in
my spine like somebody was stabbing my
[__] spine with a knife you know what
that's like though and then you're
thinking to yourself well maybe I should
quit
I'll throw that coke away I ain't
throwing that [__] cocoa I don't care
if they stab me 80 times in the [__]
spine today I'm not gonna throw that
[__] Coke away
you know it was 418 pounds when I quit
doing cocaine do you know that no they
were [__] cutting it with ice cream
I don't know what the [__] they were
cutting that coke with they were cutting
it with [__] jelly sandwiches or
something [__] we jelly double knits get
them
wow towards the end I was doing heroin
for three months that summer I was doing
heroin
Jeff whatever his name was gaming
Oxycontin one night I had a little piece
I thought I was gonna [__] diely
I couldn't believe I was to that part of
my [__] life
so the drug thing I'm so [__] happy
Jesus [__] Christ man yeah Jesus
[__] Christ so these moms man this is
really nice that you're doing this [__]
and it's eight o'clock at the Improv
Sunday 7 30 7 30 you my girl are they
gonna feed them now we're gonna feed
them yeah we're gonna feed him there too
Philip she was just here on the show two
weeks ago oh good yeah she's gonna be
honest with her little soft voice and
[__] I love her and Mickey Mouse charm I
talked to her today she was going on a
date tonight oh she was I had to talk to
Felicia and I have the same mother her
mother was is was white and mine is
Puerto Rican but we have the same mother
like when I wanted to see her one woman
show I was like that's my life
from the food stamps to the pill
addiction to everything it was it's very
interesting how we have such parallel
lives
that's a tough [__] life man
yeah it's a tough life it gets you
somewhere maybe in the front maybe in
the middle maybe at the end
but it's gets you somewhere you're so
cute
yeah that's but it's the [__]
realities of this [__] you know
and that's what people can't figure out
they have they get stuck in a problem
and they can't figure out how to bounce
out of the [__] problem
and sometimes it takes years and at
least it took me 30 [__] years to get
out of the drug habit right 30 years how
to get out 27 years of your life you you
look at your life when you're in a
hospital bed when you're [__] 80 and
you go I gave 27 years to a Coke habit
Jesus [__] Christ you know that's why
if you listen to the show I mean you
know
you're not going to quit until you're
ready to quit that's right
I'm not gonna lie to nobody and told you
tell you I can tell you guys I made a
promise to a cat and that's why I'm here
I was just ready to [__] quit I was
just so frustrated with my life
I was so frustrated with comedy and I
knew that if I quit I would give comedy
a chance for reals you know what I'm
saying like give it a comedy a chance
for reals like give your life a chance
for reals I still talk to people
but I quit nine years ago and they're
still doing at the same rate I was doing
it today and I can't believe it I
couldn't even imagine I could not
imagine doing a line of comfort in my
nose right now I have a great time
eating animals with Lee and smoking pot
is all I need you never got the uh urge
not even [__] close
that's crazy close I've thought about
like what would it be like to get an ape
on and bring a waitress up here now
today
it wouldn't even work for me I would get
a nervous breakdown yeah and you'll have
a nervous break so many different types
of addiction too like people look at
drug addicts and think like I remember
going to the hospital with my mom and
somebody was saying she's not like a a
drug addict she just takes pills and I'm
like no she's drug addict just like any
other drug addict she'll she sold the
television for some Percocet that's a
drug addict that is that you don't have
in in women with men you know sometimes
you're addicted to that bad dude that's
your drug but we all have addictions and
addiction is is a [__] it's
really hard to I was in a bad
relationship for many years and my
friends call them heroin because they
were like you keep going back to that
[__] it's gonna kill you one day and
that that same I had to take I had to
stand up and say I don't want to do this
anymore I don't want to die
because that's what what it what it felt
like it felt like death was upon me
so I watched my mom and I um you know
I've done like nine interventions with
her and I go back and I try to get her
you know
and I'll go to Al-Anon because the
doctor was like your mom's an addict but
you're crazy because you think you're
gonna you're gonna rescue her and she's
gotta want to do it herself
and so we just sit and wait and hope
that one day she stops because that
Percocet is real look look what happened
to Prince I never liked I never nothing
in my life
sorry I said that I never understood
for the Al-Anon
you know like I never went to an Al-Anon
meeting
I just had a friend who you know a white
dude in Boulder what a brother or
anything anymore so he went to Al-Anon
meeting and when I'm doing coke with him
I was sitting there doing an eight ball
and he's telling you know his brother's
an addict and you know he's always
trying to help his brother and I'm like
what the [__] do you people add more
drama to this cleanliness [__] you know
so it's another form of addiction you
are addicted to the addict that's what
it is it's another form of addiction you
you you're addicted to the drama you
know you are addicted to it
and it's it's the you know it's the it's
the weirdest thing in the world to watch
somebody and I grew up around drugs I
grew up around cocaine and crack you
know
my uncle used to buy um God Rest his
soul my favorite uncle he used to buy
stuff from Fingerhut he used to order
[__] from Fingerhut all the time right
and then would sell it for the drums and
one day he caught a cab to the apartment
building where I grew up in and I could
hear the cab driver cussing him out and
he ran up into the apartment and came
back with the silver platter and tried
to pay the cab driver with the platter
because he was a crackhead and the cab
driver took the platter and started
hitting him with it he was like
[__] I want my money it was
crack he would do he jumped off the
balcony of my grandmother's house with a
figura a porcelain knick-knack and ran
down the street and sold it because my
grandmother would lock him in the house
and he took the knick-knack jumped out
the balcony and went and sold it for a
rock
you know I did one day my grandmother
went to collect the rents and the man
that every apartment that she went to
they'd be like Oh I'm sorry though we've
already gave you the rent to your son
and by like the six apartment she knew
he had collected all the rents she went
and got the gun because she was going to
shoot him because she was like I gotta I
don't know what I'm gonna tell the owner
because he stole all the rents he would
go and binge on drugs cocaine crack
heroin he would go for three or four
days disappear and then come back like
nothing happened
and my grandmother was waiting for that
[__] with a broomstick and she
beat him up and down 21st Court with the
broomstick until she broke the broom on
him and then she said but they will come
and mop them go get the mop because the
mop is next I grew up around addiction
my whole life my dad was a heroin addict
so I just your father too the Cuban dude
no My real father my my stepfather never
did drugs the Cuban no but my my step My
real father the the one I didn't grow up
with he he did heroin and it was my
stepfather never did a drug he he was
he his his addiction was a different
type of addiction but it wasn't um it
wasn't drugs
it's [__] up I give thanks every day
that
I think a Lee when we did the 6 a.m
podcast
I saw Jesus if I was doing coke with me
we're doing a podcast at six
the first year he would have waited for
me 10 times
I would have called him and said Lee I'm
not coming
can you imagine you can't do anything
you can't plan your life around them
like they can't keep his eyes open
because there would be no way Lee that
would get high till five
and come over here at six I'd be too
paranoid to leave the house
I would not even think of leaving my
house
every door would be like you could be
outside with the car what do you think
this would become like a party place
like you would just stay here into the
coke here so you could do the podcast oh
it would have got to a point where I
would have came here at night locked
myself in the way that chair is against
the door
lock the windows
and I would have snowed a Coke in here
but the killer in here is you got to go
outside to go to the bathroom which
means
I would repeat in those water bottles
that's how nasty I am that's how nasty
or addiction is oh yeah
nasty I did nasty things guys
one time I did an ounce of blow and I
stayed in by myself for three days I had
a dog I wouldn't walk him oh that dog
sat in that corner crying until he
finally figured out that this
[__] ain't gonna take me out
that was one of the worst things I ever
did to an animal I remember when we
stepped out he [__] on the way down the
stairs like he held it oh I wouldn't let
him out it was horrible horrible
horrible
you know you do so many [__] crazy
things man
breaking the people's houses at night
when I ripped my hand open I was
thinking of that robbery on it when I
ripped my hand open on the [__] bad
boy
and how [__] I tried to rip the
window open it wouldn't work and the
cops came and
I [__] ran 20 blocks bleeding
I had blood all over my [__] jeans
and
I went into this [__] and all I
worried about was getting out of that
night like I owe twenty thousand dollars
I owed thirty thousand dollars at that
Timely
and I told those people that I owed the
money to them and I have the money that
day so like credit card companies are
like no no no there was no credit card
companies in those days it was 1983 I
didn't have a credit card
this was the people those boys
and and what were like the consequences
be of you not paying on time I mean at
that time
they would just give you pay
plans
like I was on pay plans with like four
different [__] people oh so it's not
like your legs broken no
I owe you three thousand
oh you
know 150 a week until I paid the three
thousand dollars
that's five weeks yeah
so that was a time I was coming up with
anywhere from a thousand dollars a week
to 12.50 just to keep the loan sharks
off me
can you imagine that 12 50 before your
party starts
and I'm living on the streets selling
Coke and slinging half grams and trying
to make eight balls and put [__]
together but still coming up with 12.50
every week for some [__] loan shark
yeah
but at the same time trying to snort and
do whatever the [__] I'm doing
it's a [__] horrible life man and I
don't wish anybody and if
listen like I said nothing I know for a
fact that nothing you will leave or Ada
or
when somebody's going through this [__]
they have to go through on their own and
get a couple talks and [__]
but if you play the game they'll go to
55 rehabs they're rehabbing the rehab is
a break
those rehabs are just a break for you
it's like it's like putting a prisoner
in jail when you put a prisoner in jail
like a convict like a real [__]
criminal he goes in jail to learn yep he
learns to become a better Criminal he
lives so when he comes in like let's say
he goes in there let's say he's a drug
Smuggler but he bumps into Lee and Lee
is an international [__] drug
Smuggler a guy who ships 50 pounds a
[__] hour we [__] blow and
whatever
he'll learn those things now in those
routes what do you think happens when a
[__] drug addict goes to rehab they
talk to other druggies and all of a
sudden they go you didn't know you could
[__] fake prescriptions of CBS
which one the one in Studio City yeah
there's a Chinese guy you don't look at
you know that's it that's it you just
opened up a door that addict just has
something in their mind that if they get
out of they want to use again they're
going to [__] get high trust me I did
that [__] I want the wrong one rehab
I went to one rehab that was a six-week
rehab and I knew it was a scam at the
age of [__] 27 to 28 I went to a
rehab it was outpatient where you go
from six to nine yep and I knew it was a
scam Lee I was like this is going to be
the biggest scam in 10 years and it sure
did become at what point do you know as
a scam
I think it's a Band-Aid
I think when you go to rehab it's a
Band-Aid I'd rather take the twenty
thousand dollars I'm going to pay lee to
put eight in and take 10 and take lean
in [__] Montana
and take it to a [__] cabin up in the
mountains where she has to exercise and
if she escapes she's got a hitchhike 60
[__] miles to the nearest buck
station which means she's gonna have to
blow some [__] body for gas or
they're gonna [__] molester because
it's just cowboys up there
you know and even then
it's not a guarantee it's just a lapse
in the addiction and when you don't do
drugs the addiction continues to grow
if I went and did Coke again it would
take me a week and a half and I'd be
right back doing an eight ball at night
it would take me a couple nights to do a
a couple bumps and maybe a half a gram
then a half a grand then maybe a grand
but that's like two three weeks I'd be
right back where I was going baby a
[__] two grams a night and three
snorts two grams and three small potato
that'll kill you
and next thing you know that's what
happens is they go people go back to the
doses that they were doing before and
they think their body can handle it and
their bodies can't handle and that's
when you gotta know D yeah
do you have people offering you drugs
now
marijuana and Edibles and mushrooms
never never
tell you what
because when you're an addict to cocaine
when you're an addict to meth
when you're an addict to heroin believe
it or not what I'm going to say to you
guys you're gonna think I'm crazy but
you send off a certain sin mm-hmm you
send off a certain Salem
met people no met people and when people
no heroin people cocaine people no
cocaine people as stupid as it sounds
as dumb as it sounds you're gonna look
at me and go Joey you're [__]
[__]
well you said it earlier when you said
uh people looking like what you did put
this out in the morning looking for
what's up like that it's do you know
this people like if you're just driving
oh yeah you'll just be like oh yeah that
guy's looking forward I could tell when
somebody hasn't slept now I could tell
because of the body language I can tell
when somebody
is on coke and I can also tell when
somebody is on coke and their eyes and
their noses wide open yeah they're
playing it cool but they're looking for
the next package oh I can see I can say
so all they're looking for is a wall on
the floor a jacket hanging a purse
unattended that's all they're looking
for you know I know because I know how I
would stand
I know how I would position myself I
know how I would look
but nobody in 27 years of a heroine of a
cocaine addiction
not too many people came up to me and
offered me heroin unless I asked for it
okay in 27-year cocaine addiction
nobody came up to me and offered me meth
where the shooting and the smoking I
know nothing about that world because
nobody ever came up to me and offered it
to me you know many people in the last
you know 20 years I did Coke how many
people came up to me and asked me if I
want to own Posse
a lot
a lot more than any of the above when I
was doing coke people wouldn't even come
up to me and talk to me about rifa
they would talk to me and then say hey
man I got some [__] Coke that'll
knock your [__] wig off let's go do a
line we go do a line we come back and
you get more yeah I got more in my
pocket what do you want I'm looking for
80 a gram you got two for 150 yes I do
boom that's how quick the sale was with
me
and that happened in every city
I could go into a bar and spot a Coke
guy within 15 [__] minutes
and within 25 I'm talking to him and
within 30 I either score or we're taking
a ride to go get more coke
is that the [__] craziest thingly
it's like an older you pull out that
your body puts out or something it's a
body language yeah let me give some
shout outs I went to uh
uh Indianapolis and and one band came in
on the one night hero Junior they're
[__] Savages I played uh the CD today
also cavemen came in and left me a CD I
haven't listened to that one and also
another guy came and left me a CD thank
you guys you guys uh
a real [__] towns and I'm gonna
listen to all these CDs and see what you
[__] in Hindi and what the
indie sound is all about also uh
trujitsu revolution.com it's
um I make my main man uh
what the [__] I'm too [__] high right
now man you know what I'm saying my main
man map Baker's style of jujitsu up in
Bakersfield
go to
bakersfieldbjj.com right now and say
hello Dustin Bates Brian nawatru Henry
Abernathy Phillip Cox Bruno Diaz Cody
Harrell Jeff Corman and happy birthday
Jimmy [__] pets and [__] happy
birthday Jimmy
[__] sucker anyway
so the Mother's Day sorry we went off on
the tangent of [__] eating pills and
snorting people's [__] how you doing
over there you ready for another start
that
at this point no I'm not gonna start now
what are you up to right now 850 850. so
you need to do 150 to break yeah I've
done over a thousand what did you do
over a thousand a bunch of times wait
give me the dates of the book
I was in Vegas a couple times
and then here if you eat over a thousand
times I'm gonna give you a surprise
when you put the podcast up you come get
me I'm gonna take you for something that
it's been a secret I was holding out for
your next birthday but I'll take you
over this surprise it's open until
then you'll be I guarantee you'll kiss
me and [__]
you'll say Joey how'd you know I like
this stuff
I can't talk now why how are you gonna
be tonight when you go home what do you
got at the house tonight turkey sliced
dead turkey
it's been in there since Tuesday it
smells terrible
what do I have I don't have much I don't
know
so what are you gonna go eat you have to
stop anyway you're gonna be too high
that's where Uncle Joey comes through
yeah we're gonna take me somewhere maybe
talk to people I'm not when do I take
you anywhere to talk to people when when
do I take you anywhere and expect you to
talk to people you think I want to go
mingle and we just talk about that we
just had a whole [__] paragraph about
mingling and you're telling me you want
to [__] go mingle and [__] look at
the shape of me do you think I want to
mingle I don't even want to talk to the
waitress
if there's a way I can write a note to
the [__] waitress I would do it I
don't want to take you to Denny's or to
your favorite spot and poison you
because that wouldn't be nice if you had
a thousand Millions you're looking for a
nice steak pizza oh something you know
oh my God look at the shape I had it
now you're a mom how many kids you got
all together two
with this dude
and where's the X today and uh he lives
in Georgia you communicate with him
um as minimally I don't talk to him my
kids talk to him because they're older
now so they can talk to him themselves
yeah are you divorced legally Legally
divorced yeah that's it you just started
all over again and got this there's
another thing me and Felicia right
both talk about that yeah
so uh yeah I have two kids and my kids
live in California and we live
far away from everybody
and they grew up just like I grew up
they're paranoid and they don't know
anything and I'm so happy that they're
like that they have they very they value
our family values
they're old school kids
mom mom is
reign supreme
Emily at least
yeah moments are always the no more I
mean
especially if Dad's work it's
moms are
I can't imagine my life now my mom was
alive
first off I wouldn't be the man I turned
out to be today I would still be a soft
[__] you know I'd be a sore [__] with
excuses and safety that you know what
I'm saying
so sometimes I'm happy and sometimes I'm
sad that she's dead I always say that
that I would have been
very uh I knew how I was living that she
always had my back yeah so you know I
could tell her whatever you know what
I'm saying I mean
uh I got left back I never thought no
how did you get away with that because I
kept a fall away from that [__]
school
I kept it far away from the school and I
had a check that would reprint my report
card with eighth grade on in seventh
grade
so we were straight before a year or two
I had a player like I was enough for a
year I had to make believe I was in high
school
so she'd give me money for the bus the
whole [__] thing she would have
killed me before she would have found
that and she was going to find out
eventually
she's gonna find that in a year or two
mom
mom I feel bad about all those things
you know
I'm trying to write something now
because like we said when you write
something
a TV show or book or something we always
try to write about something to be
intelligent about but the best work
you're gonna do
is what you're passionate about you know
and I always thought about what my life
would be like if my mom was in it with
my white wife and the baby and how she
would try to raise the baby oh she
raised me in 2016. that's right now
between you and I and I know it would
work
but in my wife's eyes it wouldn't work
right absolutely you know it just
doesn't work on paper but it works I
would not let my mother do a bump in
front of her that's too much that was
just a bit much I wouldn't let my
my mom smoke pot in front of her
if she had to take it to a Met game
I guess that's okay
of course it is if she had to take a
shot because she would spoil it I guess
that'd be okay
and I'd want my mom to
uh pass over that tough woman
mentality it's not a mentality it's it
takes moving getting a tattoo
it's a lot more than a woman saying
she's a feminist in all the words they
use my mom was Cuban she didn't know any
of those words that's right but she
respected Womanhood you know
I remember being older and she telling
me about women who show LA papaya I hear
them saying when there was something
about my mom you know she would always
say to me yeah if uh you know you know I
don't like sucking dick but but I do it
anyway whatever said I don't like making
my bed she's I don't like sucking
business
I knew my mother was crazy
I wouldn't want to say those things
around Mercy but I would want her to
my mother always gave you a sense of
importance that you mattered and she
gave you a sense of respect and why are
you crying fix your shirt you gotta look
nice for people you don't have to let's
go get your nice shirt
you know when you after a conversation
with her you were put back together she
knew how to put you back together when
you lost your [__] mind and I used to
lose my [__] mind and I see Mercy
losing her mind today
and Terry adds few of the fire
and that's why she comes over to me
because I try to I work out like my mom
used to work me
crying about wipe your tears you don't
want people to see you crying you know
I'm saying pick up your shirt pull up
your shirt you don't want people to see
your titties come on sit up straight but
Daddy and I grab her and I hold her I
want that message still and if a
[__] [__] with you you break
his [__] head you know all that thing
my mother really always pushed me not
being a follower yep
okay you know you know why are you doing
this [__] that they're doing yeah [__]
you know what I'm saying like she you
know made me believe that you have to
stand up against things for yourself I
don't want to do it I don't want to you
know the other day the last thing I want
to do is call Uber
like it was the last thing I wanted to
do was call [__] Uber
like once I call Luke that puts me in a
different time zone in my brain you know
what I'm saying like then I cross the
line
there's so many things I keep sacred I'm
trying to keep sacred for myself my
mother took a cab everywhere
you know what I'm saying I was just
about to take a cab but I made a mistake
I called The Armenian limousine drive
and he called me back and said give me
your credit card number and I didn't
have my wallet on me so I'll call him
later and I forgot about it so I was
embarrassed to call him back so I
thought they forgot they showed up
they showed up I was ready to call Uber
they called and said we're outside for
your ride bring your coffee
so right now somebody's playing bingo
with my [__] thing
[__] Bulgarian [__] what else has
been going on when you talk to me stand
up boys I've been working
um I've been in New York a lot that's
where I've been you know really like uh
working my working the comedy I just
recorded an album last week and uh at
the stand in New York
and I've been working at The Cellar and
I've been working at the stand
um I did Robert De Niro's movie
um the comedian a bomb like a
[__]
in the beginning of the year okay and um
he selected uh some he handpicked
certain comedians foot and I was one of
them and uh we recorded at the village
underground so I've been working I've
been you know you know some of the
things that I've been doing I've been
really working on my um my TV show stuff
and uh auditioning I'm going to do uh
Comedy Central next week I'm doing the
nightly show next Monday what's the
nightly show your friend Larry Wilmore
okay what are you doing over there they
just I'm doing a panelist okay I've been
on that before look at you but I said
that before
I watched it and it was the most Bland
[__] comic I ever saw in my life hand
man Obama first of all I don't want to
see the president doing [__] comedy
he's not a stand-up well that's not that
he's a stand-up he should be somewhere
fight nice yeah you know what I'm saying
I don't want to see all the Saturday
night fighting stuff with tuxedos with a
bunch of black people
and white people that's it you're a
[__] president enough is enough
they're either on Saturday Night Live
jumping up with Jimmy Kimmel I wonder is
that you're the [__] president yeah
you're the [__] president it's like a
social thing they've all been on late
nights
did you see that video he made with the
vice president I didn't like that no you
know and there's just enough time but
that when I went back to the room saying
I couldn't sleep and I had it on for a
little while and I was dying to [__]
boredom I'm like look at these people
laughing at what
[__] are they like I think the funniest
thing Obama said tonight
that Larry Wilmore didn't make me
[__] laugh one time he was dying in
that [__] room they didn't know what
to do those white people what did he say
about Trump I don't [__] him know but
they act like you know like they really
like Larry they don't [__] like
nobody unless those people want to see
Seinfeld bring Seinfeld and he would
have ripped that room oh my God
that joke was so witty
the watered down white people do yeah no
I can't listen to that [__] so I ca you
know I can't I can't I can't I'm too old
it's all I don't even react to that [__]
it's like Jesus Christ how bad was that
I watched him he said a couple things
that I then I read the next day he said
[__] or son I don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__] what's it got to do
with us Lisa yeah we're on [__] 900
milligrams of that day what do you give
a [__] about right now he said what's on
your mind
Lee
hello
I don't know what's on my nothing's on
my mind you know I'm thinking about
Cheeseburger so I'm telling the truth
well when you brought up in and out I
was thinking that was a pretty good
place to have a panic attack like you
could just eat then
for the food
the line was too long you know that line
over there was ridiculous the people of
the car the car they were the line was
I'm happy that you didn't get mad at me
because I didn't give it to you
advertently you said you didn't want it
so I left it on the table you reached
out so I said all right eat with you I
don't think you once you ate it I
thought that you knew what you were
doing well mad at you for what you know
this is
some people like I said I just heard a
little Vibe about this about 10 days ago
that uh
a couple convenes like we every time we
go on there we get too high you know and
it's like
you know what man this is just an escape
for two [__] hours
if you want I'll pay for your [__]
Uber you tell everybody you oh my God I
got an edible I got 180 milligram
chocolate bar in my travel bag
some guy came up to me the other night
Indianapolis and gave me one of those
chocolate bars I buy over there the ones
we used to eat when we used to eat 180
and split them yeah he gained with us I
took the box and I put it in my [__]
bags in case I needed one on the
airplane
you never know when you get in the urge
for chocolate on the [__] airplane
you know what I'm saying
that's right so uh mad at you
that's why I got I got a lot of love for
you because you were like you know most
people would have told everybody I went
on the podcast named a star I ended up
in the hospital [__] I think it's funny
that's funny it's funny as [__] some
people got no sense of humor and uh no
you know they tell everybody how they
smoke dope and everything and all of a
sudden they come over here to Uncle
Joey's laugh no yeah I thought I hear
Bill Cosby no no far from that come on
I always feel safe when I'm around you I
don't feel you're too familiar to me
like yeah like family that's I've never
I've done a lot of bad things I've never
dosed a woman's drink or nothing like
that I'd give them I've given women
aspirin and told them it was cocaine
they're crazy [__] like that but I know
the other [__] you did the reverse you
did that [__] a favor yeah
tell me
six of those times I actually saw the
girl's Jaws moving
and they would tell me how good the coke
was and [__]
I would give them little lines of
aspirin at least say it the placebo
effect
it's [__] crazy Lee
look at the shape of we live live out
here look at the shape of laying stuff
Liz got his hand folded like this you
see that oh yeah he's all retardled out
to them look at him he's got a little
hoof hand and [__]
what's up buddy I'm all [__] out you
gave me whatever it is okay you hear
what he says you game I didn't give you
nothing what do you mean he didn't give
me maybe nothing what'd I give you this
stars in the table you've reached and
you got it yeah
don't give me nothing what are you
talking about
oh yeah [__] really see what I'm
saying
you know what I'm saying about the youth
of America
by the way they want a red yeah and [__]
I don't understand this he's lucky I
love this stuff
I don't know anybody could be listening
to D.A FBI the Cubans
the Cubans listen to everything
[__] yeah those Cubans listen to Russian
[__] rock stations and everything
they don't [__] around Jack
let's get to these [__] ads and we'll
Abandon Ship here this is one of my
favorites man I've been getting a lot of
emails on this and you do what the [__]
you want but you know I tell you guys
how it is all right it's okay you can
admit it the last thing that you want to
do after work is wait online at a
grocery store or Supermarket then you
gotta schlep home then you got to cook
up a complicated meal cook [__] you
gotta feed the cats you gotta take care
of their kids this is what you need in
your life hell no and all this stuff is
expensive and unhealthy takeout is
hardly any better that's where a new
service called Blue Apron comes in Blue
Apron delivers Farm Fresh listen to me
fun fresh ingredients with step-by-step
recipes to your home allowing you to
create healthy handcrafted meals at home
without going to the grocery store so
boom so by the time you get home there's
a box in front of your house sealed
Frozen tremendous you bring the box in
you walk in you open up the box all the
stuff comes in little portions already
with the recipe and the frying pan not
only do you learn
how to cook which is a [__] gift
because they make great stuff you learn
how to cook all this stuff they send you
fresh ingredients perfectly proportioned
making cooking healthy meals easy and
fun no more trips to the grocery store
you didn't forget nothing plus you
learned how to cook with ingredients
that are normally hard to find it's
perfect for date night cooking with
friends and they even offer a family
plan with kids friendly ingredients
let's say you get any peanuts they'll
send you Kung Pao with [__] green
chili or whatever the [__] [__] your kid
let me whatever so the whole family can
eat well and have fun preparing the
meals together each balanced meal is 500
to 700 calories per serving and so tasty
you wouldn't even know it cooking takes
half an hour shipping is flexible and
free and the menus are always new they
won't send you the same meal twice they
work around your schedule and your
dietary preferences and the Blue Apron
experts Source only the best seasonal
ingredients for incredible meals like
crispy cod tacos and spring chicken
fettuccine with asparagus on the side
that's the [__] the the the the
whatever plan the two-person plan the
family plan next week
seeded chicken with vegetable hash and
swiss cheese and caramelized onion Patty
melts are you [__] kidding me or what
you'll cook incredible meals and you'll
be blown away by the quality and the
freshness Blue Apron is a better way to
cook so do me a favor right now no
[__] around I'm gonna give you first
two meals for free on me go to
blueapron.com slash Joey j-o-e-y [__]
that's how you do it my treat the first
two meals on me when you go to
blueapron.com Joey do yourself a favor
listen you got one foot in the grave one
a banana peel you don't got time to come
home and cut and cook and go shopping
bam Blue Apron delivers it right to your
door why mess around go to blueapron.com
Joey j-o-e-y and get two free meals on
me [__] suckers what do you think about
that I'm going to Blue Apron for later
you know what I'm saying
slash Joey hold on all right again this
whole thing for the last two years I've
been on it and I love it anything to do
with on it I would at least give it a
shot that's what you're into it's I'm
not sitting here telling you that I go
on the t-booster I'm not sitting here
telling you that I go on the uh should I
do the Almond uh banana
uh my Dolce protein even though Lee
liked it I'm stuck on the hemp chocolate
I'm stuck in the on the
and what else what's the other one I'm
stuck on the pills that give you more
energy
yeah
that's what works for me because I fly
that's where the immune comes in
and when I go to Jujitsu I'm a fat [__]
so I need every bit of oxygen I can take
so I take the shroom Tech sport you know
I struggle in the end whatever but now
that I'm in better shape the shroom Tech
is really taking me out to like when you
roll and stuff like that so I'll tell
you what I can sit here and tell you
about a bunch of [__] I don't know
anything about what I usually tell
people is go to audit.com right now just
go to on it read about shrimp Tech read
about the m-force protein read about the
kettlebells read about all the great
stuff they got I can only help you with
the supplements I'll get you 10 off your
first order and it gets delivered to
your door that's the best deal I can
give you and if you want to do the stay
on it program you can do that and get an
additional 10 off and that gets
additional that gets sent to your door
on a monthly [__] level but let's
start with just going on it and looking
at the great supplies uh the great
supplements that they have in stock read
about the the t-boost to read about all
this [__] and then get back to me
there's something you want I'm giving
you 10 off tonight give him the coldly
church c-h-u-r-c-h bam gives you 10 off
like a [__] so go to honda.com
and go look at the great line of
supplements the best one of the best
products I use them I love them
especially when I lift weights so I go
to Jujitsu so your balls ain't flying
around me on these [__] whether
you're wearing suit or sweats you spend
24 hours a day in your underwear but
instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes you wear underwear that's
[__] boring they're yellow they got
[__] [__] stains on them and then you
expect people to lick your nutsack
listen me undies is here to change that
every pair of me on these is made with
substantially sourced model a fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton nothing
could describe the FIT and feel of me on
these but once you try them you'll
understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear and
if you don't love your first pair
underwear
they're free no questions asked me on
these ass Dungeons and styles limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear whether
anyone can see them or not remember
Superman [__] shipping is free in
the US and Canada and you save up to
eight dollars a pair with the Beyond
these subscriptions plan get the
subscription or a single pair and we're
going to give you 20 off your first
order when you go to me on these.com
slash Joey that's beyondes.com Joey but
20 off your first order again
meanddies.com Joey I want to thank Ada
for coming down tonight God bless you
the Improv 730 Ada Felicia Michaels uh
Lori kilmartin Laurie Martin Laurie Kim
Martin
is the first headline I ever opened for
as a feature act wow you want me to tell
you what year
September of 1995.
21 years I know Laurie come up wow I
even drove it to the airport that week
it could be a nice feature
boom she was the first person I ever
opened for as a feature act in a major
club like I had featured before but one
night is no no no this is at the [__]
Comedy Underground
in Seattle Washington who the [__] you
think you're dealing with
so dropping mad props on all you girls
for doing the show on Sunday night thank
you very much for coming thank you for
having me it means the world that you
came down here and you're doing
something for mothers you know if my
mother was around I'd [__] take it
down and have a laugh at you and [__]
like that she'll be there in spirit
that's right what's your web page
funnyaida.com everything's funny either
okay I have a short film dropping
tomorrow so make sure you go to my
website funny item come on number two
this week sat Sunday Saturday night I'm
in San Francisco with Andrew Dice Clay
at the Washington theater I don't even
know if that's correct the following
week I'm in Sacramento at the punch line
the following week
Pittsburgh oh [__] The Improv bam just
like that
I see you [__] Thursday night
or Wednesday stay black see you tomorrow
on Periscope thank you for the love Ada
thank you thank you for having me Lisa
yet thank you bad [__]
please
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign